we're also happy that elon musk is now
taking over twitter
we like it not because elon is some
rock-ribbed right-wing conservative
but because he's certainly not woke he's
certainly not with the left
and he has gone in and he's bought nine
percent of twitter more than nine
percent of twitter
and he was offered a seat on the board
of directors
initially he was going to accept this
seat
then we got some news that that elon
musk is not going to take the seat on
the twitter board of directors the first
reaction from conservatives to this was
disappointment we were crestfallen oh no
we were so close to changing twitter we
were so close to taking back the public
square oh no why won't elon musk do it
now that some information is coming out
as to perhaps why elon musk didn't take
the board seat the reaction has been
elation so this from perag agrawal who's
the ceo of twitter
elon musk has decided not to join our
board we announced on tuesday that elon
would be appointed to the board
contingent on a background check and
formal acceptance elon's appointment to
the board was to become official
effective uh april 9th but elon shared
that same morning that he will no longer
be joining the board
okay
no further explanation but this is how
aggraval signs off the letter the
decisions there will be distractions
ahead but our goals and priorities
remain unchanged the decisions we make
and how we execute is in our hands no
one else's let's tune out the noise and
stay focused on the work in what we're
building
what do you mean there are going to be
distractions what do you mean it's going
to be a bumpy road ahead what are you
referring to
your main antagonist elon musk just said
he's not going to join the board
well here's what's in the contract that
they initially gave to elon musk
said mr musk will agree that
for so long as mr musk is serving on the
board and for 90 days thereafter mr musk
will not either a loaner as a member of
a group become the beneficial owner of
more than 14.9
of the company's common stock
outstanding at such time including for
these purposes economic exposure through
derivative security swaps or hedging
transactions
so the deal was we'll give you a seat on
the board if you agree not to up your
stake in twitter right now you own nine
percent nine and change well you can't
own fifteen percent or more if you join
the board but one board seat isn't
actually that powerful so more and more
it looks as though twitter offered musk
the board seat not to give him a seat at
the table but to actually reign in the
power because he's gone in and he's now
the single largest shareholder in
twitter it's not that easy
to buy nine percent of a company like
twitter
it's not like elon just picks up the
phone he says bye bye bye sell sell sell
no this is a complicated process
he's doing it because he wants to
influence the company and what this says
to me
is that
what this says to me is that elon musk
is not interested in pulling back from
this whole twitter game
it says to me that he's interested in
taking it on much more potentially a
hostile takeover here which would be one
of the most important things we could do
in this country for free speech in the
defense of the traditional american way
of life do it elon go on i'm reading the
tea leaves here i've got my nostradamus
hat on don't let me be wrong go in
hostile take over boot out these woke
idiots give us back our public square
i'm glad you liked that clip now i'm
just i'm going to make it very simple
ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications check out the other videos
you can also get the audio podcast on
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play at the michael knowles show leave a
five star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]